over an hour late donald trump has
arrived at the cpac
conference in florida about to make his
first
speech since leaving the white house
speaking there to an audience
of american conservatives taking a long
time to clap his audience perhaps as a
thank you for their
rather long wait and they haven't heard
from him for a few weeks he's of course
been
silenced by social media and so
his usual outlet for letting us know how
he thinks
and uh we've not had a huge amount of
reaction from him
since his impeachment trial of course
where
he was cleared but where a number of
republicans from his own side
voted against him we're told he may have
scores to settle tonight
perhaps with some of those republicans
but also of course with his successor
joe biden he will no doubt be in his
sights in this speech
willie announced that he'll run for
office again in 2024
the experts think not the crowd no doubt
would like him to
he's got a lot of supporters at that
conference
so a long build up to him starting to
speak maybe he particularly likes this
song
[Music]
we know that he's going to go for joe
biden on the subject of immigration
we've been told that
and although he's not expected to
formally say that he'll run in 2024
he is expected to talk about
his political journey being far from
over
and there's been a straw poll taken
there amongst those grassroots
conservatives that this
cpac conference represents that it's the
largest annual gathering of those
grassroots conservatives in the us
and a straw poll has been taken amongst
them and they have put donald trump
as their top candidate to run in 2024
he's the most popular person there and
actually there's the signs of his
popularity throughout
the conference not least amongst the
speakers who are attending
but also the general mood there as well
interestingly mike pence mitch mcconnell
not speaking there
aside perhaps of the schism that still
remains within the republican party
[Music]
[Applause]
well thank you very much and hello cpac
do you miss me yet
do you miss me
a lot of things going on
to so many wonderful friends
conservatives and fellow citizens in
this room and all across
our country i stand before you today
to declare that the incredible journey
we've begun
together we went through a journey like
nobody else there's
never been a journey like it there's
never been a journey so successful
we began it together four years ago and
it
is far from being over
our movement of proud hard work and you
know what this
is the hardest working people
hard-working american patriots
is just getting started and in the end
we will win we will win
we've been doing a lot of winning as we
gather this week
we're in the middle of a historic
struggle for america's future
america's culture and america's
institutions
borders and most cherished principles
our security our prosperity and our very
identity as americans is at stake
like perhaps at no other time
so no matter how much the washington
establishment and the powerful
special interests may want to silence us
let there be no doubt we will be
victorious and america will be
stronger and greater than ever before
[Music]
i want to thank my great friends matt
and mercedes schlapp
matt thank you thank you mercedes thank
you very much
and the american conservative union for
hosting this extraordinary event they're
talking about it all over the world man
i know you don't like that but that's
okay
all over the world i also want to pay my
love and respect
to the great rush limbaugh
who is watching closely
and smiling down on us he's watching and
he's loving it and he
loves catherine katzman thank you for
being here so
great thank you kathryn he loved you
catherine i will tell you that
so fantastic thank you catherine very
much
to each and every one of you here at
cpac i am more grateful to you
than you will ever know we are gathered
this afternoon to talk about the future
of our movement the future of our party
and the future of our
beloved country for the next four years
the brave republicans in this room
will be at the heart of the effort to
oppose the radical democrats the fake
news media
and their toxic cancel culture something
new to our ears cancel culture
and i want you to know that i'm going to
continue to fight
right by your side we will do
what we've done right from the beginning
which is to win
we're not starting new parties
you know they kept saying he's going to
start a brand new party
we have the republican party it's going
to unite and be stronger than ever
before
i am not starting a new party
that was fake news fake news no
wouldn't that be brilliant let's start a
new party and let's divide our vote
so that you can never win no we're not
interested in that now we have
tremendous uh mr mclaughlin just gave me
numbers that nobody's ever heard of
before
more popular than anybody that's all of
us it's all of us
those are great numbers and i want to
thank you very much those are incredible
numbers i came here and they were giving
me 95
97 92 percent
i said they're great and i want to thank
everybody in this room and everybody all
throughout the country throughout the
world if you want to really know the
truth
thank you though thank you
we will be united and strong like never
before
we will save and strengthen america and
we will fight the onslaught of
radicalism socialism and indeed it all
leads to communism
once and for all that's what it leads to
you'll be hearing more and more about
that
as we go along but that's what it leads
to you know that
we all knew that the biden
administration was going to be bad
but none of us even imagined just how
bad
they would be and how far left they
would go he never talked about this
we would have those wonderful debates he
would never talk about this
we didn't know what the hell he was
talking about actually
[Applause]
his campaign was all lies talked about
energy i thought i said you know this
guy actually he's okay with energy he
wasn't okay with energy
he wants to put you all out of business
he's not okay with energy he wants
windmills the windmills
the windmills that don't work when you
need them
joe biden has had the most disastrous
first month
of any president in modern history
that's true
already the biden administration has
proven
that they are anti-jobs anti-family
anti-borders
anti-energy anti-women and anti-science
in just one short month we have gone
from
america first to america last
you think about it right america last
there is no better example than the new
and horrible crisis
on our southern border we did such a
good job it was all worked
nobody's ever seen anything like we did
and now he wants it all to go to hell
when i left office just six weeks ago we
had created the most secure border in
u.s history
we had built almost 500 miles of
great border wall that helped us with
these numbers because
once it's up you know they used to say
wall doesn't work well
you know what i've always said walls and
wheels those are two things that will
never change
the wall has been amazing it's been
incredible and little sections of it to
complete they don't want to complete it
they don't want to complete little
sections in certain little areas they
don't want to complete but
it's had an impact that nobody would
have even believed
it's amazing considering that the
democrats number one priority was to
make sure that the wall
would never ever get built would never
ever happen
would never get financed we got it
financed we ended catch and release
ended asylum fraud and brought illegal
crossings to
historic lows when illegal aliens
trespass across our borders they were
promptly caught
detained and sent back home
and these were some rough customers i
want to tell you some rough
customers were entering our country it
took the new administration only a few
weeks to turn this
unprecedented accomplishment into a
self-inflicted humanitarian
and national security disaster
by recklessly eliminating our border
security measures controls all of the
things that we
put into place joe biden has triggered a
massive flood of illegal immigration
into our country the likes of which
we have never seen before they're coming
up by the tens of thousands
they're all coming to take advantage of
the things that he said that's luring
everybody to come to america
and we're one country we can't afford
the problems
of the world as much as we'd love to
we'd love to help but we can't do that
so they're all coming because of
promises and
foolish words perhaps worst of all joe
biden's decision to cancel
border security has single-handedly
launched a youth
migrant crisis that is enriching child
smugglers vicious criminal cartels
and some of the most evil people on the
planet
you see it every day just turn on the
news you'll see it every day
under my administration we stop the
child smugglers
we dismantle the criminal cartels we
greatly limited drug and human
trafficking to a level that
nobody actually thought was possible and
the wall helped us a lot
and we protected vulnerable people
it's ten o'clock you're watching sky
news we're live in florida as former us
president donald trump makes his first
public appearance
since leaving the white house at a
conference of american conservatives
well listen again
and it has done so in a very very big
way
under the new administration catch and
release
has been restored can you imagine we
work so hard catch you know what that is
you catch them
you take their name they may be killers
they may be
rapists they may be drug smugglers you
take their name and you release them
into our country
we did the opposite we not only didn't
release them we had them brought back to
their country
illegal immigrants are now being
apprehended
and released along the entire southern
border just the opposite of what it was
two months ago they weren't coming
because they couldn't get in
once they think they can get in they're
coming and they are coming at levels
that you haven't even seen yet
by the hundreds of thousands by the
millions they'll be coming
the biden administration is now actively
expediting the admission of illegal
migrants
enabling them to lodge frivolous asylum
claims and admitting them
by the thousands and thousands and
thousands a day crowded together
in unsanitary conditions despite the
ongoing economic and public health
crisis covet 19 or as i call it the
china virus
there's no masks there's no double mass
that was a new one that came out two
weeks ago
first vauch he said you don't eat mask
no mess no good no no then all of a
sudden you want him and now he wants
double masks
no social distancing nothing
no nothing they're together
and it's sad actually and it said for
them and it said for our country
what the biden administration is doing
to push
young migrants into the hands of human
traffickers and coyotes is dangerous
immoral and indefensible hard to believe
it's happening
biden has failed in his number one duty
as chief executive
enforcing america's laws
this alone should be reason enough for
democrats to suffer withering losses in
the midterms and
to lose the white house decisively
four years from now
[Applause]
actually as you know they just lost the
white house but it's one of those things
but who knows who knows
i may even decide to beat them for a
third time okay
joe biden defunded the border wall and
stopped
all future construction even on
small open sections that just needed to
be finished up
routine little work it's already been
bought
wait till the contractors get to them
and they say no it costs us much
more money not to finish the small
section than if we finished it that's
going to be nice where do you see those
bills start pouring in he revoked the
executive order cracking down on deadly
sanctuary cities
he has effectively ordered a shutdown of
ice halting virtually
all deportations everyone murderers
everybody
no more let's not deport people and
restricting our law enforcement
professionals and they are great
professionals you have many of them
represented here today
from conducting almost any immigration
enforcement of any kind
the biden policy of releasing criminals
into the u.s
interiors making america into a
sanctuary nation
where criminals illegal immigrants
including gang members and sex offenders
are set free into american
communities they have no idea who's
coming up and remember with the caravans
these countries not only the three of
them
but many many countries all over the
world they're not giving us their best
and their finest
because they're intelligent they're not
giving us their best
and their finest remember i said that i
said that
a long time ago when i made the first
remarks when i came down the escalator
with our great future first lady
who says hello who loves you as much as
i love you
but i said that a long time ago and we
turned out to be
100 correct biden's radical immigration
policies aren't just illegal
they're immoral they're heartless and
they are a betrayal of our nation's core
values it's a terrible thing that's
happening
the republican party must hold joe biden
and the democrats
accountable they ripped up the
diplomatic agreements we negotiated with
honduras guatemala
and el salvador to shut down illegal
immigration
you know they got a fortune they got
paid 500 million dollars a year
when i came into office those countries
were
refusing to take back illegal alien gang
members including ms-13
the most vicious probably of them all no
matter where you go in the world ms-13
they do things that
even the worst don't think about so i
asked how much do we pay these countries
how much do we pay them sir we pay them
approximately 500 million dollars a year
that's a lot of money
i mean it's peanuts compared to the way
other countries rip us
off but that's a lot of money i said
okay
we aren't going to pay them anymore
because they wouldn't take back the
criminals and this was true with the
obama administration it was true for
many many years
so we'd catch a murderer we'd want to
bring them back to guatemala or
honduras el salvador
they wouldn't take them back no we don't
want them we'd fly them in they wouldn't
let the plane land we'd bust them in
they wouldn't let the buses
get anywhere near the border and i said
we're not going to pay them anymore
so after i said that and i stopped
payment you know
like a term that we use in the world of
business let's stop payment
so we stopped payment they were
delinquent
we stopped payment and they very quickly
came to the table and we made a deal
very quick deal
we still kept the money we still didn't
pay because
but we made a deal
[Applause]
and when illegal aliens came across our
border
they were rapidly deported and lovingly
accepted by those countries
from where they came and it worked out
great so now they
accept the people and then we ultimately
got along very well with those
countries those three countries and many
countries throughout the world because
they respected us again
they didn't respect us they couldn't
believe what they were getting away with
but now joe biden has wrecked this great
deal
wrecked it and they're already doing
what they were doing before and they're
taking the money
and that's just a small portion of
what's going on to top it all off
the biden people are pushing a bill that
would grant mass amnesty for millions of
illegal aliens
while massively expanding chain
migration that's where
you come in and everybody comes in your
grandmother your
father your mother your brother your
cousins
they come in so easily so so crazy
so crazy it even requires that the u.s
government provide illegal border
crosses
with taxable funded lawyers lawyers
anybody need a good lawyer you can't
have one
they get the lawyers they get lawyers
they're probably very good too
the democrat immigration bill is a
globalist corporate
you take a look at the corporatists big
tech attack on hard-working citizens of
every race religion
color and creed and republicans must
ensure that it never
is allowed to become federal
law which is what they want to do
[Applause]
we must stand tall in the party
we have to do this we have to stand tall
as the party
for law abiding americans
and others when they're in our country
border security is just one of the many
issues on which the new administration
has already betrayed the american people
he didn't talk about this stuff i
debated him he wasn't talking about this
he wasn't
what he signed with those executive
orders
they weren't things that were discussed
we didn't know all about
him and the press because they're fake
news they're the biggest fakers there
are
but the press
refused to ask the questions and when i
asked the questions on
television on the debate chris wallace
in this case and others
refused to let him answer they refused
to let him answer the
questions maybe we could have found
something or if the media did its job
which they don't
their callous indifference to working
families equally clear when it comes to
the critical matter of getting america's
children back to school
and they must get back and get back
right
now right now crazy
terrible the biden administration
is actually bragging about the classroom
education they are providing
to migrant children on the border while
at the same time millions of american
children
are having their futures destroyed by
joe biden's anti-science
school closures think of it we're
educating
students on the border but our own
people the children of our citizens
citizens themselves
are not getting the education that they
deserve there's no reason whatsoever why
the vast majority of young americans
should not be back in school immediately
the only reason that most parents do not
have that choice
is because joe biden sold out america's
children
to the teachers unions
his position is morally inexcusable you
know that
joe biden has shamefully betrayed
america's youth
and he is cruelly keeping our children
locked in their homes no reason
for it whatsoever they want to get out
they're cheating the next generation of
americans out of
the future that they deserve and they do
deserve this future they're going to
grow up
and they're going to have a scar it's a
scandal of the highest order and one of
the most
craven acts by any president
in our lifetimes it's the teachers union
it's the votes
and it shouldn't happen and i have
nobody has more respect for teachers
than i do
and i'll bet you a lot of the people
within that union they
agree with everything i'm saying even
the new york times is calling out the
democrats
the mental and physical health of these
young people is reaching a breaking
point
tragically suicide attempts have
skyrocketed
and student depression is now
commonplace
and at levels that we've never seen
before
the democrats now say we have to pass
their 1.9 trillion dollar boondoggle to
open schools but a very small part of it
has to do with that you know where it's
going it's going to bail out
badly run democrat cities so much of it
but billions of dollars for schools
remain unspent
from the covert relief bills that were
passed last year
so on behalf of the moms dads and
children of america i call on joe biden
to get the schools
open and get them open now be a great
thing to do
when i left office and were very proud
of this because this was something that
they said could not be done
the fda said it everybody said it any
article you read said it couldn't be
done it would be years and years i
handed the new administration what
everyone is now calling
a modern day medical miracle some say
it's the greatest thing to happen
in hundreds of years hundreds of years
two vaccines produced in record time
with numerous
others on the way including the johnson
and johnson vaccine that was approved
just yesterday
and therapeutic relief also if you're
sick
if you're sick we have things now that
are incredible what
has taken place over the last year under
our administration
would have taken any other president at
least five years
and we got it done in nine months
everyone says five years
five years
can you imagine if you had to go through
what all of the countries of the world
who are now
getting the vaccine or soon will be
getting it from
various companies but can you imagine if
all of those countries had to go through
what they've been going through over the
last year you'd lose
hundreds of millions of people i pushed
the fda
like they have never been pushed before
they told me that
loud and clear they have never been
pushed like i pushed them
i didn't like them at all
but once we got it done i said i now
love you very much
what the trump administration has done
with vaccines has in many respects
perhaps saved large portions of the
world not only our country but large
portions of the world
[Applause]
not only did we push the fda far beyond
what the bureaucrats wanted to do
we also put up billions and billions of
dollars 10 billion
to produce the vaccines before we knew
they were going to work
it was called a calculated bet or a
calculated risk we took a risk
because if we didn't do that you still
wouldn't have the vaccines you wouldn't
have them for a long time so think of
that we took this
this bet we made a bet because we
thought we were on a certain track
but you'd be starting to make them right
now would be
a long time before you ever saw them it
takes 60 to 100 days to manufacture
and inspect new doses and that means
that 100
of the increased availability that we
have now
was initiated by our administration
100
[Applause]
in fact the director of national
institutes of health
francis collins he's fouchy's boss
actually i think he's a democrat too by
the way
recently said that our operation warp
speed was
absolutely breathtaking and that the
trump administration
deserves full credit which we do
and as conservatives and republicans
never forget that we did it
never let them take the credit because
they don't deserve the credit
they just followed now they're following
our plan but
this has been something that they really
call they call it a
an absolute miracle joe biden is only
implementing the plan that
we put in place and if we had
an honest media which we don't they
would say it loud and clear
by the time i left that magnificent
house
at 1600 pennsylvania avenue almost 20
million americans had already been
vaccinated
1.5 million doses were administered on
my final day alone
1.5 million in a day yet biden said just
a few days ago
that when he got here meaning the white
house there was no vaccine
he said there's no vaccine oh good
say it again joe
now i don't think he said that frankly
in a malicious way i really don't
i actually believe he said that because
he didn't really know
what the hell was happening
but
never let them forget this was us we did
this
and the distribution is moving along
according to our plan
and it's moving along really
well we had the military what they've
done
our generals and all of the people what
they've done is
incredible but remember you know we took
care of a lot of people
including i guess on december 21st we
took care of joe biden
because he got his shot he got his
vaccine he forgot it shows you how
unpainful that vaccine shot is so
everybody go get your [ __ ]
he forgot so it wasn't very traumatic
obviously
but he got a shot and it's good that he
got a shot
last year i predicted to you that the
extremist
corruption and incompetence of the biden
administration
would be literally unprecedented in
american history
unfortunately he has proven me 100
percent
right already
as president biden has urged congress to
pass legislation
shredding your second amendment your
second amendment is in far bigger
trouble than you
know and for four years i fought like
hell to save your second amendment
and we saved it 100 percent
we saved it he signed an order to
conduct
correct far-left indoctrination
trainings in every department of the
federal government
including the u.s military after i had
terminated
these horrible things that were being
preached to our military
and he wants it to go forward it's
insane
within his first few hours biden
eliminated our national security travel
bans or nations plagued by terrorism
his first priority was to open our
borders to unvetted travelers from
libya yemen syria somalia and many other
countries where strict vetting
cannot occur countries that have
tremendous problems
countries with tremendous terrorism
problems we did a travel ban it was
a real achievement we told those
countries sorry
straighten out your act we don't want
people coming in
where they had an ideology or a problem
we just couldn't have it
and it was incredible how it worked was
incredible
and he terminated it we had to get it
approved it went all the way up to the
supreme court of the united states we
got it approved and he terminates it
in addition he's already increased
refugee admissions by nearly 10 times
but in effect it'll soon be hundreds of
times as millions of people flow up
through our soon-to-be open borders
and by the way the border patrol and
isis are some of the great heroes of our
country these are incredible people
i got to know him very well
your family still cannot go out to eat
at local restaurants but joe biden is
bringing in
thousands upon thousands of refugees
from all over the world
people that nobody knows anything about
we don't have crime records we don't
have health records
what are they bringing in with them when
i left office
we had virtually ended the endless wars
these endless wars they go on forever
they go on forever
i would go to dover and i would see
caskets coffins coming in i'd see the
parents and the wives and husbands i
would see
the kids endless wars 19 years in
afghanistan we have it down to
almost nothing left and i hear they
might want to go back in
iraq remember i used to say don't go in
but if you're going to go in keep the
oil well we went in and we didn't keep
the oil
we had made historic peace deals in the
middle east
like nobody thought were even possible
with not a drop of bloodshed
and by the way not one american soldier
has been killed in afghanistan
in over a year think of that not one
those troops have largely come home at
the same time
the new administration unilaterally
withdrew our
crippling sanctions on iran foolishly
giving away all of america's leverage
before
negotiations have even begun leave the
sanctions negotiated
does anybody understand what i'm saying
here
are there any good business people you
don't have to be a good are there any
bad business people
they took off the sanctions they took
off the sanctions they said well we're
going to not
have any sanctions let's negotiate a
deal i don't know matt schlapp i don't
think you would have done that do you
think so man i don't think so mercedes
wouldn't that
now you do that you make a deal and then
you do it they wanted
i will tell you something and i said it
had
we had a fair election the results
would have been much different and we
would have had a deal
we would have had a deal with iran
within the first week they wanted those
sanctions off he took them off for
nothing
for nothing now you watch how tough they
negotiate
in another horrendous surrender he
agreed to
get back into the world health
organization
for approximately 500 million dollars a
year which is what we were paying
when i withdrew from the w.h.o
and you know the whole story with that
they called it badly
they really are puppets for china
they called and they wanted us to stay
in i said
how much are we paying approximately 500
million dollars how much
is china paying a much larger in terms
of population
country sir they're paying 39 million
i said why are we paying 500 million and
they're paying 39.
i could tell you why because the people
that made the deal is stupid that's why
so so
and i had no idea how popular it was i
didn't even know if i would be able to
politically because people were so happy
when i did get out
but i said so we went in we could get it
for 39 million which is what china not
500 million which is what we were
stupidly paying and they said
we can make a deal we want you to go in
we can make a deal
okay and i did i decided not to do it
but we could have had it for 39 we could
could've had it for the same as china
and they decide now to go back into the
world health organization
and pay 500 million what the hell is
wrong with them
no no this is just this is just
emblematic
it's a tremendous amount of money but
compared to trillions it's not but it's
a tremendous amount of money
why would china pay 39 million and we're
paying almost 500 million
why so we could have made the same deal
that china had 39
million and they just say we're going
back in we're going back into the world
health organization they go back in they
pay 500.
it is so sad just like the iran
and the world health organization joe
biden put the united states
back into the very unfair and very
costly
paris climate accord without negotiating
a better deal
they wanted us so badly back in i'll
tell you they wanted us i was getting
called from all of the countries you
must come back into the paris accord i
said tell me why give me one good reason
first of all china doesn't kick
in for 10 years russia goes by an old
standard which was not a clean standard
in other countries but we get hit right
from the beginning would have cost us
hundreds of thousands and millions of
jobs it was a disaster
but they go back in i could have made an
unbelievable deal and gone back in but i
didn't want to do that surrending
millions of jobs and trillions of
dollars
to all of these other countries almost
all of them
that were in the deal so they have
favorable treatment we don't have
favorable treatment and we just said
we're going back in
to go back in they wanted us so badly
you could have negotiated if you wanted
to go back in
which frankly we have the cleanest air
the cleanest water and everything else
that we've ever had so i don't know why
we have to
and what good does it do when we're
clean but china's not and russia's not
and
india is not so they are pouring fumes
you know
the world is actually a small piece of
the universe right
they're pouring fumes and we're trying
to protect everything and building
products for
three times more than is necessary no
they could have made a great deal if
they were going to go back in that's
fine
but they could have made a great deal
instead of just say we're back in
these people and in one of his first
official acts
which was incredible because again he
talked about energy he never said he was
going to do this he cancelled the
keystone xl pipeline
destroying
not the 8 000 or the 9 000 or the 11 000
jobs that you hear
but 42 000 great paying jobs
on just about day one right he never
talked about that during a debate
because he wouldn't have gotten away
with it well he would have because they
cheated so much it probably wouldn't
have been
no but that was not a topic of
conversation remember
fracking you can frack oh we love
fracking during the primary
no fracking as soon as he got through
that he said no of course everybody can
break no fracking
you wait do you see what happens with
your gasoline when you see what happens
and
we cannot let this stuff continue to go
on
one of my proudest accomplishments as
president was to make america energy
independent the united states became the
number one
energy superpower on earth
number one
became number one bigger than saudi
arabia bigger than russia by a lot
we left them all in the dust they were
all in the dust
but if the democrats have their way we
are heading from
energy dominance to energy disaster
that's what's happening
you have to see what's going on
everything's being closed up
it's a disaster the blackouts we saw in
california last summer and
all the time and the windmill calamity
that we're witnessing in texas
great state of texas we love texas but
it's so sad when you look at it
that'll just be the start how bad is
wind power so i talk about it all the
time at cpac right we went to
cpac remember last i said we're going to
watch the president
well uh alice the wind isn't blowing i
don't believe we'll have any electricity
remember we would
we would kid but i wasn't actually
kidding it's
such an important such an expensive form
of energy
it's so bad for the environment it kills
the birds it destroys the landscapes
and remember these are structural
columns with
fans on them they wear out and when they
wear out all over the country you see
them
nobody takes them down they're rotting
they're rusting
how this is environmentally good for our
country and it costs
many many times more than natural gas
which is clean it costs many more
and can fuel our great factories wind
can't do that and
and solar i love solar but it doesn't
have the capacity to do what we have to
do
to make america great again sorry it
just doesn't happen
under the radical democrat policies the
price of gasoline has already surged
thirty percent since the election
and will go to five dollars six dollars
seven dollars and even higher so enjoy
that when you go to the pump and they'll
say that'll be about uh
two hundred dollars to fill up your van
you'll go to this remember this used to
go to the little small vans they got
away from the big ones that everybody
wanted they went to the small ones well
you know what probably a good investment
as long as these guys have their say
because you know it's
it's a shame what's happening energy
prices are going to go through the roof
and that includes your electric bills
that includes
any bill having to do with energy our
biggest cause
we will now be relying on russia and the
middle east
for oil and they talk about russia
russia russia what's better than what
this guy's done for russia
i had oil where they were actually
paying you to take it okay you know
that was a little remember they were
going to give you 37 a barrel but got to
take it away
you had free oil almost for a period of
time and one way i was proud of it but
we also had to save the energy industry
and it worked out well and i dealt with
russia and saudi arabia
and they cut back on production and we
got it
back up but now it's going the opposite
because now they're taking this
incredible
energy independence away from the people
of our country and you're going to see
costs go like you have never seen them
go before
it's a very sad and very stupid thing
that they're doing
the biden policies are a massive win for
other oil producing countries and a
massive loss for the united states and
our great citizens
joe biden and the democrats are even
pushing policies that would destroy
women's sports
a lot of new records are being broken in
women's sports hate to say that ladies
but
got a lot of new records they're being
shattered
you know for years the weightlifting
every ounce is like a big deal for many
years
all of a sudden somebody comes along and
beats it by a hundred pounds
now young girls and women are in sense
that they are now being forced to
compete against those who are
biological males it's not good for women
it's not good for women's sports which
worked
so long and so hard to get to where they
are the records that stood for years
even decades are now being smashed with
ease
smashed if this has not changed
women's sports as we know it will die
they'll end it'll end what coach if i'm
a coach
you know i want to be a great coach what
coach as an example wants to recruit a
young woman
to compete if her record can easily be
broken by somebody who
was born a man not too many of those
coaches around right
they are around they won't be around
long because they're going to have a big
problem when
their record is we're oh and 16 but
we're getting better
no i think it's crazy i think it's just
crazy what's happening
we must protect the integrity of women's
sports so important
after
and i don't even know is that
controversial
no somebody said well that's going to be
very controversial
i said that's okay you haven't heard
anything yet
as you can see the early weeks of the
biden administration of nothing less
than
they've been a catastrophe for american
workers and for american families
the task of our mission
and for us it's our movement as i said a
movement like has never been seen
i think we can probably say never been
seen anywhere
in the world i mean nobody's ever seen a
movement like this i
i'd grow up and i'd watch somebody who
came in second in new hampshire or
first in iowa and that was the end and
they became famous for
the rest of their lives we won the
election twice i mean you know think
about it
the task for our movement and our party
is to stand up to this destructive
agenda with confidence and with resolve
the future of the republican party is as
a party that defends the social economic
and cultural interests and values of
working american families
of every race color and creed that's why
the party is growing so
rapidly and it's becoming a different
party
and it's becoming a party of love you
have to see outside the streets i mean
there's such love
the flag
amazing
[Applause]
you know it's a party that's incredible
the people the spirit
and there as you probably heard a little
while ago i mean there's more spirit
now than there's ever been including
even before the election more spirit now
than
we've ever seen because people are
seeing how bad it can be
and again i want to thank rush and
catherine because
what he did to get the word out has been
incredible
some people are irreplaceable as sean
hannity would say and he said
rush is irreplaceable but his spirit
lives on and that's
something that we need and we love
republicans believe
that the needs of every citizen must
come first
in fact america must come first we don't
put it first
they don't put it first over the past
four years my administration
delivered for americans of all
backgrounds like never before
like never before we built the strongest
economy in the history of the world
raised wages and achieved the lowest
african-american hispanic
hispanic-american
asian-american unemployment rates ever
ever
ever recorded
it was so great for everybody of all
backgrounds
that even after the china virus
we are leading the world nobody's even
close we're leading it in the comeback
our economic comeback has been
incredible that's because the financial
and economic foundation we built was so
strong that unlike other countries were
having a hard time
we didn't break we came roaring back and
now
our stock market and your 401ks are
again at record levels higher than ever
before actually
many people have asked what is trumpism
a new term being used more and more i'm
hearing that term more and more
i didn't come up with it but what it
means is great deals great trade deals
great ones
not deals where we give away everything
or jobs or
money like the usmca replacement of the
horrible nafta nafta was one of the
worst deals ever made probably the worst
trade deal ever made
and we ended it you know a lot of people
forget we ended it now we have the us
mca mexico canada it's incredible what
it's done for our farmers who are doing
fantastically
did you see grain prices and grain sales
are at an
all-time high wheat all-time
high so many elements of farms and
farmers and they love me and remember
it's going to be very close in iowa well
it wasn't close we won in a landslide
iowa
because our farmers know and they put up
with it and we did a lot of work with
the tariffs and all these things that we
had to do to get it and now the farmers
are doing great
but they're setting records it means low
taxes
and eliminating job-killing regulations
trumpism
it means strong borders but people
coming into our country based on a
system of merit
so they come in and they can help us as
opposed to coming here
and not being good for us including
criminals of which there are many
it means no riots in the streets it
means law
enforcement
it means very strong
protection for the second amendment and
the right to keep and bear arms
it means support for the forgotten men
and women
who have been taken advantage of for so
many years and they were doing great
they were doing great before that
horrible thing from china came in and
hit us
and now they're starting to do really
well again you know if you think about
it we built the economy twice we built
it then
and then like every other country in the
world it went down
and then we built it again now it's
higher in many ways certainly in the
stock market it's higher in many ways
than it was before that's because of the
foundation
and no country comes even close to
competing
with our comeback and it means a strong
military
and taking care of our vets but a strong
military
which we have totally rebuilt we have
rebuilt it
and our military has never been stronger
than it is today
it was tired it was depleted it was
obsolete and now we have the best brand
new equipment ever made
and it was all produced right here in
the usa isn't that nice
and we take care of our vets you know we
had a poll
recently just before leaving office the
vets had a 91
approval rating for the way we took care
of them that's the highest number
in the history of the polls
the vet polls on top of all of that
we have even created the space force the
first new branch of the united states
military
in nearly 75 years
the mission of the democrat party is to
brought socialism they want to promote
socialism
ultimately leading unfortunately to
communism
and that will happen if you look at
venezuela you look at some of these
countries that's why some of our biggest
supporters
are from south america latin america
because they've seen what goes on
with all of this cancer culture and you
can't speak
and let's cut them off and let's not
give them words
the mission of our movement and of the
republican party must be to create a
future of good jobs
strong families safe communities a
vibrant culture
and a great nation for all americans and
that's what we're creating
their party is based upon unvarnished
disdain for america
its past and its people you see that
happening it's horrible
the way they treat the legacy of our
country the culture of our country
our party is based on love for america
and the belief that this is an
exceptional nation
blessed by god
we take great pride in our country
we teach the truth about history we
celebrate
our rich heritage and national
traditions
we honor george washington abraham
lincoln thomas jefferson
and all national heroes and of course
we respect our great
american flag
thank you thank you very much
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much
i started that hearing we really were
were
getting word of that hearing that during
some of the rallies especially the
latter rallies where we set
records we had 56 unbelievable packed
rallies
and nobody's ever had anything like we
had and we started hearing we love you
and i asked somebody you know because we
really liked ronald reagan right he was
a great president we had others
but i said did anybody ever say that to
ronald reagan or to any of our
great and to the best of all of these
political professionals knowledge and
pollsters nobody's ever heard that chant
before man
so it's an honor it's believe me it's an
honor
great honor it's a great honor
you know when you think about we love
you you're saying that about
i hate to say it am i a politician i
don't know
maybe i'm a problem i hate to i hate to
admit it
but that's really it's an honor that you
would say we believe in patriotic
education and strongly oppose the
radical indoctrination of america's
youth
horrible we are committed to defending
innocent life
and to upholding the judeo-christian
values
of our founders and of our founding
we embrace free thought we stand up to
political correctness and we reject
left-wing lunacy and in particular
we reject cancer culture
we know that the rule of law is the
ultimate safeguard
and we affirm that the constitution
means
exactly what it says as
written as written
they want to change it they want to
change it they want to get rid of it
frankly
we believe in law and order and we
believe that the men
and women of law enforcement are heroes
who truly deserve
our absolute support we don't defund the
police
we are not defunding
we believe in standing up to china
shutting down
outsourcing bringing back our factories
and supply chains
and ensuring that america not china
dominates
the future of the world that's what's
going to happen
and by the way we took in hundreds of
billions of dollars from china
during my administration hundreds of
they never gave us 10 cents it was a
one-way street we took in hundreds of
billions and during negotiations they
would say
look the one thing we don't want any
more of these tariffs these tariffs
those tariffs we took in so much money
and what happened is
they became competitive so what happened
with
people they wouldn't go to china they'd
build a lot of it back in our
country they would make it here instead
and in addition to that
we would take it in billions and
billions and billions of dollars from
china
but in all fairness to china they we
made a trade deal with them
this was prior to covet once covert
happened i no longer cared so much about
the trade deal
because what happened with that was just
disgraceful
but that's one of the things that's one
of the reasons that right now our
farmers are doing so good i used to
celebrate look
look go and get a lot of wheat get a lot
of different things all of the things we
just talked about
you better go out and do it because this
country
has not been treated fairly by you for
many many years
many many years we used to lose 504
billion dollars trade deficit with john
500 for not million 504 million
a lot right you know that through
the world health organization now take
504 million make it 504
billion dollars we had deficits with
china it was absolutely insane that this
could keep going on it's amazing that
you still have a country left
the people that did this to our country
they should be ashamed of themselves
they should be ashamed companies that
leave america to create jobs in china
and other countries that have ripped us
off for years should not be rewarded
they should be tariffed fined and
punished
they should not be rewarded
[Applause]
and that's what the biden administration
that's what the biden administration is
doing but of course as you know they
have a very close personal relationship
with china so i don't
i don't expect much to happen it's a
shame
because it really is a threat it's a
tremendous economic
threat and thank god we've rebuilt our
military
but it's a tremendous economic threat
never forget it these are the
convictions that define our movement
today
and must define the republican party in
the years ahead
very simple it's really quite simple
isn't it
another one of the most urgent issues
facing the republican party
is that of ensuring fair honest and
secure
[Music]
elections
such a disgrace such a disgrace
[Applause]
such a disgrace we must pass
comprehensive election reforms
and we must do it now the democrats use
the china virus
as an excuse to change all of the
election rules without the approval of
their state legislatures
making it therefore illegal
it had a massive impact on the election
again you have to go to the legislatures
to get these approvals
this alone would have easily changed the
outcome of the election
at levels that you wouldn't have even
believed even with
covid even with all of the things the
numbers are
staggering we can never let this
or other abuses of the 2020 election
be repeated or happen again can never
let that happen again
you see what's going on we've been set
back so greatly
with other countries and with the world
we need election
integrity and election reform
immediately republicans
should be the party of honest elections
that can give everyone confidence
in the future of our country without
honest elections who has confidence
who has confidence this issue is being
studied and examined
but the reality is you cannot have a
situation where ballots are
indiscriminately pouring in
from all over the country tens of
millions of ballots where are they
coming from they're coming all over the
place
where illegal aliens and dead people are
voting
and many other horrible things are
happening
that are too voluminous to even mention
but people know i mean it's being
studied and
the level of dishonesty is not to be
believed we have a very sick and corrupt
electoral process that must be fixed
immediately this election was rigged
and the supreme court and other courts
didn't want to do anything about it
[Applause]
two
[Applause]
if you just take that one element where
they didn't go through legislatures it's
illegal you can't do it
it's in the constitution they didn't
have the courage the supreme court
they didn't have the courage to act but
instead
used process and lack of standing
i was told the president of the united
states has no standing it's
my election it's your election we have
no standing
we had almost 20 if you think of it we
had almost 20 states go into the supreme
court
so that we didn't have a standing
problem they rejected it
they rejected it they should be ashamed
of themselves
for what they've done to our country
they didn't have the guts or the courage
to make
the right decision they didn't want to
talk about it
you had the case led by the great state
of texas
18 states went in you don't have
standing oh let's not talk
about it they didn't have the guts to do
what should be done
and that's on top of all of the other
forms of cheating but this is the most
basic of all
they would have local courts and local
politicians change the rules in some
cases
a day or two before the election they
should never be allowed to happen
to another presidential candidate or
presidential race
should never be allowed to happen
today i want to outline the steps that
we must take
to have an election system in this
country that is honest fair and accurate
we need one election day not
45 30.
one day like it's been
and the republicans don't get this and
the other things i'm going to say that
you should like the supreme court be
ashamed of yourselves
one day one day
and the only people that should be
allowed to vote by mail
are people that can so former u.s
president donald trump making his first
public appearances leaving the white
house at a cpac conference of american
conservatives there he started by asking
hello cpac
do you miss me yet and he talked about
the incredible journey we've begun
together
four years ago is far from being over
and he said our very identity as
americans is at stake he said he
wouldn't start a new party he said we
have the republican party
but he did say as far as the democrats
are concerned i
may well decide to beat them for a third
time giving his audience a hint he could
run again but also repeating his lie
that he won the election in november
2020
more analysis of his speech coming up in
the next hour along with the top stories